so in this capsule we will define
more specifically what we mean
by an agent of people then we will approach
the concept of analysis
so what do we mean by a
agent an agent in a general way is going
match to do any
entity that can do two things can
perceive his environment using
sensors and can also act on his
environment using shareholders in
English will talk about censorship and so
it's a very very general definition
so we can include the
several types of agents finally under
this definition there for example a
human would obviously be an agent in
this case if these censors would correspond
his eyes his ears and so on
assas and his other senses so that's
shareholders correspond to his hands and
his legs his mouth our way
to interact and communicate in his
environment
now a robot for is also a
agent specifically ccam error or
other types of sensors like
infrared sensors instituted him
would allow to perceive his
environment while its wheels if one
talking robot with legs wheels
synthetic or articulated arm ben that
it would allow the robots to interact
with its environment that would correspond
to its shareholders is also a
agent could actually correspond to a
software or keyboard or access reading
in hard disks would correspond to his
how to perceive his environment
then the screen and write access to
hard disk could correspond to
shareholders for the environment of a
software as we see the notion of
agencies a notion that is very general
so maybe a little more
mathematics we will design an agent
as being an agent process is crazy
a function that takes input from a
observation sequence and who is going
actually return
an action to perform given these
seven observation sequences so it has to
more mathematical way it looks like f
is a function that takes input from a
sequence of any order so that's
what the star means a number
perception variable and he associates
an action that is part of a set
the finite or infinite set of action and
really more practical way in fact the
process
we will finally implement it with a
program on really an architecture
the specific material
so here is a very very rough draft
general code agent
so what agents would take over in
input an observation and should
return to expect that
some actions
we could have a static memory
which would be variable therefore accessible by
the function and then two very reasons
general one would expect that the agent
firstly from his perception
his observations updates his memory
which would give its new value for
his part even eymery afterwards from her leaving
of his memory would take what would be
according to the agency the best action to
take this would be the action that would have
returned by the agent here at the end
obviously we make sure that the agent gets
reminiscent of his time armed action at jo
his memory from the action that has
been chosen that went back to the all
end and so that's a very draft
very general 2
which actually corresponds to many types
implementation of money for so
implement an agent the other in a
specific context so see example
a very very simplified example for good
understand so need a vacuum cleaner
robotic one would have a vacuum cleaner that
would be in an environment with two
only pieces the room the room b and
then in every room but he could
to have
if we leave the dust in this case
observations so the data
sensory that would be given as input
to the agent that would be the position so the
room in which the robot is located
then the inventory then we could
have a combination of I'm at
the room supports the own where I get
finds room from the rooms or
well I'm at room b then she
is clean where I was at the piece
b then the rooms and all the
possible actions in what if that
could be to move left
so piece b to the piece moved to
parts right by the aspirate psb
in the room in question to pass
from a dirty room to clean rooms or
do nothing then not move or sucked
so in this context our function f
implicitly it would correspond to a
series of associations of associations
pardon between what is the series of
observations given to me and then
what is the action taken by this agent
there you have here an example of a few
actions that would be taken in
specific contexts among others
possibly that the agent if our robot
this was in a room in the
pop piece which was clean but in
what if he will decide to go right
to see if the room on the right the room
b and then hall if it's dirty anymore
you rather decided to draw inspiration for the
break up and dense only if our process
agents in fact he can act in a
context where there
life arbitrarily long so there is a
long-term observation man in long and
down in this case we have an example
agents or in fact considering
only the last observation for
take his action so as in the
case here where we had a single
observation
the action will be conditioned only
on the last to know if the piece to
and well room we breathe and then if the
room is clean
according to the last observation but I
I'll rather move to the right so
make the function we can see it as
a very long list of all
actions taken possibly by the agent
in different contexts depending
different observations
but when you see it implement it's going
really being implemented by a
function that will not necessarily li
explicitly mentioned all the
possible observations so
and that's a concept we do not see
qualify as we go
explore different types of algae
to learn from intelligence
artificial but conceptually
really behind all these algorithms
and yet this notion of a function that
takes into account more observations
that they return actions which
leads us to talk about a rational agent
we were talking about an agent until now
but ideally we would like agents
which are are rational so so
general we will think an agent and
rational as an agent that acts
correctly depending on what he
then perceives his abilities to action
and the action determine if an action
again and it will obviously depend on
a measure of performance in some
thing that tells us how much is this
that the agent behaves well
specifically the performance measure
to take the form of a function
objective that will measure the quality of the
agent behavior so often
in the different algorithms the
objective function it's going to be a
function that honors me turning a species
scores are seen or a value that
identify how much what the agent
succeeds well in a dangerous context
it could be
is the agent won or not a
part in the context of the robot
vacuum cleaner which we have just
talk about it could be the amount of
waste suck it could be notion
more general about the cleanliness of places
is instituted and therefore from a
performance measure we can define a
little more specifically what is
told me by rational agent an agent
rational we're going to be an agent
which from a sequence
observation and knowledge
own
an agent who will choose an action that
maximizes the measure of performance so at
the rational agent some agents who
takes all the editing time that
maximizes this measure as much as possible
of performance there is such that if he had
took other actions lauret - he would have
finally got a measure of
lower performance which so that's
really the goal of swimming to ration
to maximize this measure of performance
some notes on the case
means by rationality rationality that
does not mean who it is
might not know the agent
fully his environment
he might not know which
are the effects of these actions seth
godin swimming in a game where there is a
random aspect for example rolling
dances that if we do not know with
certainty that will happen after having
launched a said rational does not mean
perfect either where does it by
rationality we see as we said
sometimes we'll talk about maximizing
the expected performance
while perfection finally that
is maximizing the performance
actual or current for example
perfect jean that fertilizes all
parts of which I gave even if a
random appearance and therefore perfection
somehow not really in
this context laurent too often there is
a random aspect in a game is
not something that is really
reaching in a context between
others where one in agent who does not have access to
all information association
environment but an agent could
so decide techniques it's more
rational rather than doing
actions to influence his
environment to do actions
just to perceive his environment
and then pick more information ok and
finally one last note
when we will be interested in 30 in
agents who in a certain autonomy to
know that they will be able to
adapt to adapt their behavior in
function of his own experience because
that it will not be an agent who is the
even from the beginning to the end of his life
but who will really improve as
and as of his life film
finally we will conclude with what we
call the model pes it's a model
who will facilitate who will concretize
finally what is an agent
in a given context
so this is a model in excess that allows
makes it easier to design
diaries in different contexts so
older newer models our
four things one to the extent of
performance we talked about until
now we also have what are the
elements that are part of
the agent environment then has it
what are the actions that the young
can perform and finally what are
types of perception observations
what can or can
other agent so they are among others
the sensors the licenses therefore use to
because of these four elements the water the
ps model actually it's an acronym for
the four elements know performance
by an actor and sincere so let's see
we are going to have two examples of a
model for example imagine that we
is in a context where a robot that
must do the taxi for different
people
because if arranged their robot taxis
examples of performance measures
Well, it might consider security
people in the taxi or the speed that
could also consider the respect of
road code obviously instituted in
its environment b the notions of voting
there is traffic so other
cars there are pedestrians and
ama the customers we moved
among the shareholders so the way that
robot to influence its environment
there is obviously the flight to consult of
change speed to accelerate and
to stop flashing to signal these
traveling to other cars and
and so on
then among the censors we will count
not just cameras or
sound
the speedometer gps institute is
so everything that brings
information to robots versus
its environment that allows for better
finally identify the configuration
of its environment
another example in this case too
rather first of all a robot we really have a
software that makes the diagnosis
automated in a medical context
so in that if it would be money
would be the medical diagnostic system
performance measurement that to be
the health of patients who are treated at
the system distortion there maybe a
certain minimization of the costs of
treatments that we will recommend to
our patients the environment will contain
obviously the patients at the hospital the
staff that could be invoked by
a given diagnosis the shareholders
but in this case it will be between
other the monitor to display
questions then the results made the
way for the diagnostic system
medical to communicate these diagnoses
maybe they could even give
a treatment explicitly and
finally the censors it could be
the keyboard the mouse that would allow
to enter between the symptoms of the
sickness of a patient is disemboweled
answers to questions and so of
after